Speaking of Psychology is taking a winter break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In December 2021, I talked to psychologist Doris Bergen and toy designer Barry Kudrowitz about what makes a great toy, what makes some toys stand the test of time, and the importance of play for both children and adults. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in January. Thank you for listening. It's that time of year when parents and other caregivers race to find the hottest toys and stock up on classic favorites. From poppets to Pokemon, from squishmallows to Legos. Toys might seem frivolous, but to psychologists, they're a subject for serious study.
《心理学说话》正在进行寒假休息，所以我们重播了过去一些最喜欢的节目。在 2021 年 12 月，我采访了心理学家多丽丝·伯根和玩具设计师巴里·库德罗维茨，探讨了是什么让一个玩具成为好玩具，是什么让某些玩具经受住时间的考验，以及游戏对儿童和成人的重要性。希望您喜欢这期来自档案的节目。《心理学说话》将在 1 月带着新节目回归。感谢您的收听。又到了每年的这个时候，家长和其他照料者争相寻找最热门的玩具并储备经典的畅销品。从指尖陀螺到宝可梦，从棉花糖玩偶到乐高。玩具看起来可能微不足道，但对心理学家来说，它们是一个值得认真研究的课题。
Researchers have long known that children learn best through play. Play is how kids stretch their brains and develop crucial cognitive, social, and other skills. and toys are a fundamental part of playtime. But what makes something a good toy? Indeed, what makes something a toy at all? Why do some toys stand the test of time, while others are just a one-season wonder? What's the difference between fun and educational toys?
研究人员很早就知道，儿童通过游戏学得最好。游戏是孩子们拓展大脑、发展关键的认知、社交和其他技能的方式，而玩具是游戏时间的基本组成部分。但是，什么才算是一个好玩具？事实上，什么才算是一个玩具？为什么有些玩具经受住了时间的考验，而另一些只是昙花一现？好玩和益智的玩具之间有什么区别？
Why do we assign gender appropriateness to some toys and not to others? How do kids' toy preferences change as they age, and how has technology change what toys are and the way kids play with toys. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
为什么我们给一些玩具贴上性别合适的标签，而另一些则没有？随着年龄的增长，孩子们对玩具的偏好是如何改变的，技术又是如何改变玩具本身的以及孩子们玩玩具的方式的。欢迎收看《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Our first is Dr. Barry Kudrowitz, an associate professor and director of product design at the University of Minnesota Twin Cities, where he teaches classes in toy product design. Dr. Kudrowitz has a PhD in mechanical engineering from the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, where he studied creativity, humor, and idea generation,
我是金·米尔斯。我们今天有两位嘉宾。第一位是巴里·库德罗维茨博士，他是明尼苏达大学双城分校产品设计的副教授兼主任，在那里他教授玩具产品设计课程。库德罗维茨博士拥有麻省理工学院的机械工程博士学位，他在那里研究创造力、幽默感和想法生成，
and he has studied how play can fuel creativity and innovation. In addition to his academic career, he's also a toy designer. Highlights of his work include the Katsup Krapper, an anthropomorphic roller skating ketchup bottle that he designed as a grad student, and the Nerf Adam Blaster, a Nerf toy sold by Hasbro more than five years. Our second guest is Dr. Doris Bergen, a distinguished professor emerita of educational psychology at Miami University in Oxford, Ohio. Dr. Bergen began her career as a pre-kindergarten and elementary school teacher. And over her long academic career, she has explored the many ways that play is crucial to children's development.
他还研究了游戏如何激发创造力和创新。除了学术生涯，他还是一个玩具设计师。他作品的亮点包括番茄酱喷射器，这是他作为研究生时设计的一个擬人化的滚轴溜冰番茄酱瓶，以及孩之宝销售了五年多的 Nerf 亚当发射器。我们的第二位嘉宾是多丽丝·伯根博士，她是俄亥俄州牛津迈阿密大学教育心理学的荣誉退休杰出教授。伯根博士的职业生涯始于学前班和小学校长。在她长期的学术生涯中，她探索了游戏对儿童发展至关重要的许多方式。
She has studied play and humor in early and middle childhood, the effects of technology enhanced toys, and cross-cultural considerations in play among many other topics. Dr. Bergen has authored or edited more than a dozen books, including her most recent, the Handbook of Developmentally Appropriate Toys, which was published in March 2021. Thank you both for joining us today. Thanks for having me. God be here. All right.
她研究了幼儿和中童期的游戏和幽默、技术增强型玩具的影响以及游戏中的跨文化考量等众多课题。伯根博士撰写或编辑了十多本书，其中包括她最近出版的《发展适宜性玩具手册》，该书于 2021 年 3 月出版。非常感谢两位今天做客我们的节目。谢谢邀请我。很高兴来到这里。好的。
So let's start with a broad question, which we usually do. What is the purpose of toys and what makes something a good toy or make something a toy at all? For example, can a stick or a rock be a toy? Actually, toys have existed for a long, long time. You can even find them in early sites. And so some of the typical toys that children still play with today, like dolls and wheel toys, things that sort, have been around for a long time. But I would say that the purpose of toys, in my view,
那么让我们从一个我们通常会问的宽泛的问题开始。玩具的目的是什么，是什么让一个玩具成为好玩具，或者说是什么让一个东西成为玩具？例如，一根树棍或一块石头可以是一个玩具吗？事实上，玩具已经存在了很长很长的时间。你甚至可以在早期的遗址中找到它们。因此，孩子们今天仍然玩的某些典型玩具，如洋娃娃和带轮子的玩具，这类东西，已经存在很长时间了。但我要说的是，在我看来，玩具的目的
is to enhance children's play, because children will play, even if there aren't any toys. They'll find sticks or they'll find rocks or they'll find other things to use in their pretend play and in their gameplay. But toys are a means of enhancing the play and making it more creative and often more elaborative. Yeah, I agree. Toys are a tool for play.
是增强儿童的游戏，因为即使没有任何玩具，儿童也会玩。他们会找树棍、找石头或找其他东西来用于他们的假装游戏和游戏玩法。但玩具是增强游戏、使其更具创造性并且往往更精心详尽的一种手段。是的，我同意。玩具是游戏的工具。
And, you know, there's a team. difference between a toy and a toy product. There are certain toys that are designed by people to be intended to be used for play. And then there's things that are not designed, you know, intended to be used for play that children still play with, like cardboard boxes and spoons and rakes and stuff, right? There's still toys, but maybe they're not toy products. And many toy products are designed by people who have ideas about what they think is good for children to play with. Maybe they think they'll learn particular things from them. They have different expectations about the toys.
而且，你知道，玩具和玩具产品之间是有区别的。有些玩具是由人们设计的，旨在用于游戏。还有一些东西并非被设计（你知道的）用于游戏，但孩子们仍然在玩，比如纸箱、勺子和耙子之类的东西，对吧？它们仍然是玩具，但也许它们不是玩具产品。许多玩具产品是由那些对他们认为什么对儿童游戏有益有想法的人设计的。也许他们认为孩子们会从中学习到特定的东西。他们对玩具抱有不同的期望。
And I would say a really good toy is one that doesn't do everything itself, but has the child do it. Unfortunately, I think some toys designed do too much, and there isn't really even room for children to do very much with them. And so those toys typically don't have very lasting value. Maybe kids will play with them for a while, learn what they do, and then they'll probably turn them into something else and use them in a different way or maybe discard them all together. And are those things that you think about, Dr. Kudrowitz, when you're designing toys or teaching people how to design toys?
我要说的是，一个真正的好玩具是那种不是自己包办一切，而是让孩子去做的玩具。不幸的是，我认为一些设计出来的玩具做得太多了，实际上甚至没有留给孩子很多发挥的空间。因此，这些玩具通常没有持久的价值。也许孩子们会玩一会儿，了解它们的功能，然后他们可能会把它们变成别的东西，以不同的方式使用，或者干脆把它们丢弃。库德罗维茨博士，当你在设计玩具或教别人设计玩具时，你会考虑这些事情吗？
I mean, I'm thinking about them, but not necessarily the students. And even when we do playtesting, it's not necessarily even the children that we playtest are thinking about those things. Oftentimes it's what is trendy or popular that they might gravitate to. But I also think that what makes a toy a good toy is that it could be. used in a variety of different contexts and it doesn't die. You know, you can use it for generations, for example, or in multiple different ways of playing. You know, like the cardboard box is a great example. We actually have a box in our dining room right now from a couch, but it's been played with
我的意思是，我在考虑它们，但学生不一定。甚至当我们进行游戏测试时，我们测试游戏的儿童也不一定在考虑这些事情。通常情况下，他们可能会被时髦或流行的东西所吸引。但我也认为，一个玩具之所以成为好玩具，是因为它可以在各种不同的环境中被使用，而且它不会过时。你知道的，例如，你可以让它历经几代人使用，或者以多种不同的游戏方式使用。你知道，比如纸箱就是一个很好的例子。我们现在餐厅里实际上就有一个来自沙发的大纸箱，但它已经被
by the children for months now and we left this giant box in the dining room. And they play with that more than, you know, all the toys we've got in so far. It's a fort. It's a rocket ship. They're drawing all over the walls. They're cutting out holes. And that was free. And it's compostable. And I think it's fantastic.
孩子们玩了好几个月了，我们就把这个巨大的纸箱留在了餐厅里。他们玩它的时间比我们目前拥有的所有玩具都要多。它是一个堡垒。它是一艘火箭飞船。他们在墙上到处画画。他们在上面挖洞。而且那是免费的。它是可堆肥的。我觉得它棒极了。
There are sort of different kinds of play, you know, of course, and different kind of toys facilitate different kinds. If you're thinking of just kind of exploratory play or manipulative play, that's one kind of toy that will work for that. If you're looking at pretend play, there's a whole range of other kinds of toys that are really facilitative of pretense. And then, of course, there's game play of all different kinds and very different kinds of toys for that. And there's certainly some overlap among those. But the type of play that the child is going to do, if it's active play, quiet play, or of various sorts, will usually need, or at least there'll be an expectation that different kinds of toys will meet the needs
当然，游戏有不同种类，不同的玩具促进不同的游戏。如果你只是考虑探索性游戏或操作性游戏，那是适用于这种游戏的一种玩具。如果你着眼于假装游戏，还有一系列其他类型的玩具，它们非常有助于假装游戏。当然，还有各种各样的游戏玩法，有非常不同种类的玩具来满足这些。这些之间肯定有一些重叠。但是儿童将要玩的游戏类型，如果是活跃游戏、安静游戏或各种各样的游戏，通常会需要，或者至少会有这样的期望，即不同种类的玩具将满足不同种类游戏的需求。
for different kinds of play. So a lot of parents think that toys come in basically two categories. And Dr. Bergen, you just described several categories, not just two, but for parents, they think they're educational toys, like those that are designed to teach science or math or reading, and then there are toys that are for fun, which covers pretty much everything else. Is that a valid distinction? And is there a difference between a fun toy and an educational toy, should there be? I mean, going back to the very first thing we talked about, the primary purpose of a toy is play.
所以很多父母认为玩具基本上分为两大类。伯根博士，你刚才描述了好几个类别，不只是两类，但对父母来说，他们认为有益智玩具，比如那些旨在教授科学、数学或阅读的玩具，然后是有趣的玩具，几乎涵盖了所有其他玩具。这种区别成立吗？有趣的玩具和益智玩具之间有区别吗，应该有区别吗？我的意思是，回到我们谈到的第一件事，玩具的主要目的是游戏。
And if the primary purpose is to teach something, it may not be a very good toy. But, you know, that being said, play is how we learn. That's how we've learned skills growing up as we learned developmental skills, cognitive skills, physical skills. And so you could also argue that no matter what kind of play, if you're engaging in play, you could argue that you're learning something. And so it's a little bit hard to separate those two, but I don't necessarily like the idea of a toy being primarily designed to be teaching you something. I would agree. I think that's maybe more of a marketing distinction. than it is a toy distinction, because I think children learn from every type of play and from every type of toy. They may not be learning a specific thing like letters or whatever the toy maker thought they would do.
如果主要目的是教导某些东西，它可能就不是一个好玩具。但是，话虽如此，游戏就是我们学习的方式。那是我们在成长过程中学习技能的方式，比如我们学习发展技能、认知技能、身体技能。因此你也可以认为，不管是什么游戏，如果你在参与游戏，你就可以说你正在学习某些东西。所以要把这两者分离开来有点难，但我并不一定喜欢玩具的主要设计目的是为了教你某种东西这种想法。我也这么认为。我认为这可能更多是营销上的区分，
But they also learn many other social and physical and intellectual skills from just about any toy toy. So I think the distinction, educational toys, is primarily a distinction for parents and for teachers and people who think that, oh, if it says educational, it's going to have a greater educational factor. The other way that educational toy could be seen is if there's a specific kind of teaching that the adult wants a child to have. And unfortunately, sometimes those kind of toys that are very specifically designed to teach a certain thing are either not used very often by the child or the child transforms them in some way into pretend or something else. And they don't exactly use them in the same way that the person who designed them thought they would use them. And I think that's an amazing thing that kids can do.
而不是玩具本身的区分，因为我认为儿童从每一种游戏和每一种玩具中都能学习。他们可能没有在学习诸如字母或玩具制造商所认为的那样的具体东西。但他们也从几乎任何玩具中学习到了许多其他的社交、身体和智力技能。所以我认为，益智玩具这种区分，主要是针对父母、老师以及那些认为“哦，如果它标有益智，它就会有更大的教育因素”的人的一种区分。看待益智玩具的另一种方式是，如果成年人希望孩子掌握某种特定的教学内容。而不幸的是，有时那些专门设计来教授某种特定内容的玩具，要么不经常被孩子使用，要么孩子以某种方式将它们转化为假装游戏或其他东西。而且他们使用的精确方式并不像设计它们的人所想的那样。我认为这是孩子们能做到的了不起的事情。
I mean, I've known parents, for example, who've decided that they never want their children to have a toy gun. And somehow, kids will figure out how to make something into a gun. If they want to play with guns, they're going to have a make-believe gun, right? I mean, it's just the creative end of childhood. Dr. Kudrowitz, you were quoted in a recent article talking about the fact that toy makers worry that kids are losing interest in toys at a younger age than they used to. Is that actually happening? And if it is, why do you think so? So this is related to the concept of age compression.
我的意思是，我认识一些父母，例如，他们决定绝不让他们的孩子拥有玩具枪。而不知何故，孩子们会想方设法把某种东西做成枪。如果他们想玩枪，他们就会弄一把假想的枪，对吧？我的意思是，这只是童年的创造力所在。库德罗维茨博士，你在最近的一篇文章中被引述说，玩具制造商担心孩子们对玩具失去兴趣的年龄比过去更早了。这真的在发生吗？如果是的话，你认为为什么会这样？这与年龄压缩的概念有关。
There's probably other terms related to this. We talked to Doris about that, but it seems like kids are playing with the stuff that the older kids were playing with in the past. And this may be more of an artifact of technology advancing to the degree that things that we used to play with in the past were, I don't want to say dumb, but they didn't have. high tech inside because that was expensive. And in today's society, you can put LEDs in anything. And it's relatively low cost. You could put motors in things and processors. And there's computers in everything, you know, in my pocket right now. And it's not that much more expensive in today's society. And so a lot of the things that children are playing with today are not necessarily video games, but they're more like technology. And in the market space, some of those things
可能还有其他与此相关的术语。我们和多丽丝谈过这个，但孩子们似乎在玩过去大龄儿童才玩的东西。这可能更多是技术发展到一定程度的产物，我们在过去玩的东西，我不想说它们是笨拙的，但它们里面没有高科技，因为那很昂贵。在当今社会，你可以在任何东西里面放 LED 灯。而且成本相对较低。你可以在东西里面装马达和处理器。每样东西里都有电脑，你知道的，我现在的口袋里就有一台。而且在当今社会，它并没有贵那么多。因此，孩子们今天玩的许多东西不一定是电子游戏，但它们更像是科技产品。在市场上，其中一些东西
kind of get lumped into consumer electronics and not necessarily in the toy aisle. And so, again, it kind of goes back to maybe marketing in some ways, but also you're not necessarily seeing kids play with the same toys as they were years ago. And there's a lot more screens and digital things in their hands. As a long-time observer of play and interviewing of adults' memories of their childhood play, I definitely agree with Barry that the way play is, the time and the experiences children have in play now has changed quite a bit. When you think back to your own playtime, or certainly many other people who have either
有点被归入消费电子产品类，而不一定在玩具通道里。所以，这在某种程度上又回到了营销问题，但你也确实不一定看到孩子们在玩多年前的同款玩具了。而且他们手里有更多的屏幕和数字产品。作为一名长期的游戏观察者以及采访过成年人童年游戏记忆的人，我绝对同意巴里的看法，即游戏的方式、儿童现在在游戏中拥有的时间和经历已经发生了相当大的变化。当你回想你自己的游戏时间，或者当然还有许多其他人，他们要么
interviewed. They recall long periods of time where they pretty much could decide what they wanted to do with the time. And the kind of play materials they had were ones that they created, they made the toy talk, or they made the toy walk, or they did whatever it was with their own imagination. And now, so many of the toys, the toy does everything. There's really not much for the child to do. And so that toy is not going to be nearly as important in terms of children's development or their interest level because if you're just, there's 10 buttons to push and you've pushed all 10 buttons, and then that's really the end of,
接受过采访。他们回忆起长长的时间，在那里他们几乎可以决定自己想用这些时间做什么。他们拥有的游戏材料是他们自己创造的，他们让玩具说话，或者让他们让玩具走路，或者他们用自己的想象力做任何事情。而现在，太多的玩具，玩具本身包办了一切。留给孩子做的事情真的不多了。因此，就儿童的发展或他们的兴趣水平而言，那个玩具将不再那么重要，因为如果你只是——有 10 个按钮可以按，当你按完了全部 10 个按钮，那基本上就到了
what you can do with the toy, usually what you see the child do is either put it away and not look at it anymore or pick it up and pretend it's something altogether different and use imagination and do something else with it. So I do think that that change and certainly that idea that experience that have gone down to lower levels is not just related to toys, but it's pervasive across a lot of other things for children today. But I do think I've often thought the people designing the technology are the ones that are having the playful time
你能用这个玩具做的事情的尽头了，通常你看到孩子做的要么是把它收起来不再看它，要么是把它拿起来假装它是完全不同的东西，发挥想象力去做别的事情。所以我确实认为，这种变化，当然还有那种体验下降到更低水平的想法，不仅与玩具有关，而且在今天儿童的许多其他事情中也是普遍存在的。但我确实认为，我经常觉得设计技术的人才是那些享受游戏时光的人，
because they're the ones that get to figure out what to do with it and so on. So it's the grown-ups who are coming up with these ideas. The kids aren't asking for the toys, To be, yeah. So are you recommending that parents give their kids like dolls that don't do anything except sit there? They still make those. I know. One of the things that concerns me a great deal is if you remember back to your childhood, maybe all summer, you didn't have anything to do except just figure out what to play with yourself. Now children's lives are very structured, both after school and in summer.
因为他们是那些能够弄清楚如何使用它等等的人。所以是成年人在想出这些主意。孩子们并没有要求玩具……是这样的。那么你推荐父母给孩子买那种除了坐在那什么都不做的娃娃吗？他们还在制造那些。我知道。令我非常担忧的一件事是，如果你回想起你的童年，也许整个夏天，你除了自己琢磨玩什么之外，没有任何事情可做。现在孩子们的日常生活安排得非常紧凑，无论是在课后还是在夏天。
And so they don't necessarily have those long periods of time where they can really create their own play world. So that's a very, very different thing that we see now. So let me ask a kind of a developmental question. Maybe this is for Dr. Bergen, although you're both welcome to answer it. But what happens to children who grow up without actual toys? Do they develop differently and are they different as adults? That's a really interesting question. I really don't know of any research that's really looked at children who grow up without play
因此，他们不一定有那些长段的时间来真正创造他们自己的游戏世界。所以这是一个非常非常不同的情况，我们现在看到了。那么让我问一个类似发展的问题。也许这是给伯根博士的，尽管你们俩都可以回答。那些在没有实际玩具的情况下长大的孩子会发生什么？他们的发展会有所不同吗，作为成年人他们会有所不同吗？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我真的不知道有任何研究真正关注过在没有玩具的情况下长大的儿童，
because the research that, let's say, would be done in a country where there were very few toys show that children play anyway. They don't necessarily have to have toys to play. So it's more of a question, I guess, if you had children who had to go to work at the six or something like that. And I don't really know that's a very important issue. Probably should be studied. But I don't really know of the case that there are children who have any play experiences. But they may be very different kinds of play experiences. They may have play experiences where they use whatever is in their environment and create their own play
因为假设在一个几乎没有玩具的国家进行的研究表明，无论如何孩子们都在玩。他们不一定非得有玩具才能玩。所以这更像是一个问题，我想，如果你有那种必须在六岁左右就去工作的儿童。我真的不知道这是一个非常重要的问题。可能应该进行研究。但我真的不知道有儿童没有任何游戏经历的情况。但他们可能会有非常不同种类的游戏经历。他们可能会有这样的游戏经历：他们使用环境中的任何东西并创造自己的游戏，
as compared to the kind of play that Barry was mentioning where they have many, many toys, but a lot of toys have all these characteristics that just require you to push a button or something like that. So I think there's a wide range of play experiences, but at least in my experience, children, even if they have 10 or 15 minutes of their own time, are going to find something to play. Going back to the last thing that Dora said,
与巴里提到的那种游戏相比，他们拥有非常非常多的玩具，但许多玩具都具有所有这些特征，只需要你按一下按钮或类似的东西。所以我认为有广泛的游戏经历，但至少在我的经验中，孩子们，即使他们只有 10 或 15 分钟自己的时间，也会找到玩的东西。回到多丽丝说的最后一件事，
on technology maybe restricting play. And that is true, that happens, but it can also be used for good. And designers can create open-ended play experiences for children taking advantage of technology. So, you know, they could create new types of musical instruments or things where children can program their own things to do whatever they want. What is the Spider-Man quote? You know, with great power comes great responsibility, you know, it's in the hands of the designer to create those good, good toys. I agree with that. I just think that if there's only one way to use a toy, that it's hard for children to use it for a long time period. So as long as, you know, there are many different
关于技术可能会限制游戏。这是真的，这种情况确实发生了，但它也可以被用于好的方面。设计师可以利用技术为儿童创造开放式的游戏体验。所以，你知道，他们可以创造新型乐器或让儿童自己编程去做他们想要的任何事情的东西。蜘蛛侠的台词是什么？你知道，能力越大，责任越大，你知道的，这掌握在设计者手中，去创造那些真正好的玩具。我同意这一点。我只是认为，如果使用玩具只有一种方法，孩子们就很难长时间使用它。所以只要，你知道的，有很多不同的
things to do with it, even if it's got a lot of technology enhancement, I think it can be a toy that has a lot of playability. So Dr. Carderowitz, one for you, do commercial toy designers think about developmental psychology while they're designing toys? I mean, do toy companies routinely have psychologists that they consult with, that they have them on staff? And are those toys different or better? Well, I think this is probably a question for Doris, because I think she was, she's consulted for those big companies. But I can say that, you know, not all toy companies are large and can afford consultation. And so, you know, it's probably generally those big, the big players that could bring
事情可以用它来做，即使它有很多科技增强，我认为它也可以是一个具有很高可玩性的玩具。那么库德罗维茨博士，有一个问题问你，商业玩具设计师在设计玩具时会考虑发展心理学吗？我的意思是，玩具公司会常规性地聘请他们咨询的心理学家吗，他们有专职人员吗？这些玩具会有所不同或更好吗？嗯，我认为这可能是一个适合多丽丝回答的问题，因为我认为她曾经是，她曾为那些大公司提供过咨询。但我可以说，你知道，并非所有玩具公司都是大型的并且负担得起咨询费用。所以，你知道，可能通常只有那些能够带入像多丽丝这样的顾问的行业巨头才能在这些事情上做到这一点。
in consultants like Doris on these, on these things. Yeah, I'll pick up on that because I did, and a lot of other developmental psychology people did do a lot of work. for Fisher Price. They had their headquarters in New York for a long long time. And they would bring us there and we would look at the toys at the stage before they were in their final stage and we would evaluate them and, you know, describe what we thought might be good developmental aspects and what would work and what wouldn't and so on. And that was really a very important thing, and that's why Fisher Price toys were always so very playable and very good for development. Once Fisher Price got taken over, I think, by another company, I don't think they still have
是的，我来接话，因为我确实做过，许多其他发展心理学界的人也为费雪（Fisher-Price）做了大量工作。他们在纽约设立总部有很长很长一段时间了。他们会把我们带到那里，我们在玩具处于最终阶段之前的那个阶段去观察玩具，我们会评估它们，并且，你知道的，描述我们认为可能是好的发展方面以及什么可行、什么不可行等等。这真的是一件非常重要的事情，这就是为什么费雪玩具总是那么具有可玩性并且对发展非常有利。一旦费雪被另一家公司接管，我想，我认为他们就不再拥有
those consultants that they did at that time. But there may be some other toy companies that do have consultants. But I already thought that was really a good process because it was at the time of where there could still be some fine-tuning of the toy, but the basic toy was already designed. And I think that made the toys really more playable and more developmentally appropriate by having that input from a psychologist. So, Dr. Bergen, you studied play in China.
像当时那样的顾问了。但可能还有其他一些玩具公司确实有顾问。但我一直认为这真的是一个很好的过程，因为正是在还可以对玩具进行一些微调的时候，尽管基础玩具已经设计好了。我认为通过引入心理学家的意见，使得玩具真正更具可玩性且更加适合儿童发展。所以，伯根博士，你在中国研究过游戏。
Dr. Cartrowitz, you worked on toy design in the Netherlands. Do the types of toys that kids like to play with very much around the world, or are they pretty much universal? I guess I would say, as far as China, I didn't see any big differences. When I was there, there wasn't a lot of, where I was, it was not a rich environment, and so a lot of the play was pretty basic. But, you know, things like balls and dolls and toy trucks and various things like that were pretty much the same there.
库德罗维茨博士，你在荷兰从事过玩具设计。世界各地孩子们喜欢玩的玩具类型差异很大，还是它们几乎是普遍的？我想我会说，就中国而言，我没有看到什么大区别。我在那里的时候，没有太多……我呆的地方不是一个富裕的环境，所以很多游戏都相当基础。但是，你知道，像球、洋娃娃、玩具卡车和各种类似的东西在那里都差不多。
They also played a lot of games outdoors. And outdoor play was very big at the time I was in China. I really don't know what it's like now. But that was quite a long time ago. What about in the Netherlands? It wasn't too different. I'm always looking for new stuff. And so being in a new environment, I felt inspired.
他们还在户外玩很多游戏。我呆在中国的时候，户外游戏非常盛行。我真的不知道现在是什么样了。但那是相当长一段时间以前了。荷兰的情况呢？没有太大不同。我总是在寻找新东西。因此身处一个新环境中，我感到很受启发。
And I felt like all the toys were cooler there because they're all, you know, different. But I was just on sabbatical actually a couple years ago there. And it was my first introduction to Montessori. And so we had our two-year-old in a Montessori daycare. And that style of play was really exciting. The toys are like real stuff. It's like, you know, prepping vegetables and cleaning and stuff. And it's turning these everyday activities, you know, into play in some ways.
我觉得那里的所有玩具都更酷，因为它们全都是，你知道的，不同的。但实际上我几年前在那里休学术假。那是我对蒙台梭利的初次接触。所以我们将我们两岁的孩子送进了一个蒙台梭利日托中心。那种游戏风格真的很令人兴奋。玩具就像真的东西一样。就像是，你知道的，准备蔬菜和打扫卫生之类的。在某种程度上，它把这些日常活动变成了游戏。
they have these kind of borderi, which are these kind of children farms, I guess, in the city. And you bring, you know, the family goes and the kids take care of the animals and they harvest vegetables and they can go and they take these little tiny kid size wheelbarrows and shovels and they go into the pasture and they pick up cow poop. And they do that for like an hour. And it's like, and it's clay. This sounds like a con. This is how you make children do work. No. And my son is like, can we go back to the farm and do more of that, right?
他们有这种类似博尔德里的东西，也就是城市里的那种儿童农场，我想是的。你会带，你知道的，全家一起去，孩子们照顾动物，他们收割蔬菜，他们可以去，他们拿着这些小小的儿童尺寸的手推车和铲子，他们走到牧场去清理牛粪。他们做这个大约一个小时。这就像是……这听起来像是个骗局。这就是你让孩子干活的方式。不。我儿子说，我们能回到农场多做点那个吗，对吧？
And it's getting out into nature, connecting with animals. You know, these are tools that aren't usually their size. And so there's some novelty about that too. Yeah. And I think that European play researchers and have studied a lot of outdoor play, because they're very much more focused on the natural environment and doing things outdoors in many of the countries in Europe, not so much here as they do there.
这就是走向大自然，与动物建立联系。你知道的，这些通常不是他们尺寸的工具。所以这也是一种新鲜感。是的。而且我认为欧洲的游戏研究人员对户外游戏进行了大量研究，因为欧洲的许多国家更加关注自然环境和在户外做事情，这里没有他们那里做得那么多。
But that's been a very strong emphasis, I think, in Europe altogether. I think, though, that what I've found is that children's types of play are very similar wherever you are. And it may be that they use a manufactured toy that is designed specifically for something, or if they're in an environment where there isn't a manufactured toy that fits whatever it is they want to do, they can invent something else to use. You can use a piece of wood to be a truck if you want to, if you don't have a real truck. You can use a rag and a ball to be a baby if you really don't have a real doll.
但我认为这在整个欧洲一直是一个非常强烈的重点。不过，我发现的是，无论你在哪里，儿童的游戏类型都非常相似。可能是他们使用专门为某种东西设计的制造玩具，或者如果他们身处没有符合他们想做的任何事情的制造玩具的环境中，他们可以发明别的东西来使用。如果你愿意，你可以用一块木头当卡车，如果你没有真正的卡车。如果你真的没有真正的洋娃娃，你可以用一块抹布和一个球当宝宝。
So I don't think that necessarily the types of things children play are that different. I do think that there are many different materials they use in different places. But pretend play and game play. and exploratory practice play, just doing over and over and expanding things. Those are all very common types of play that you would see just really wherever you were in the world, I think. So I mentioned in the intro that Dr. Cutterwood's one of your first toy designs was a pooping ketchup bottle. And Dr. Bergen, you've been quoted in a couple of recent articles about why kids are so interested in potty humor and toys that defecate. And since we're on the poop topic here, what is it about bathroom humor and potty-related toys that kids find so irresistible?
所以我认为孩子们玩的东西类型不一定有那么大不同。我确实认为他们在不同地方使用了许多不同的材料。但假装游戏、游戏玩法和探索性练习游戏，就是一遍又一遍地做并扩展事物。这些都是非常常见的游戏类型，我想，无论你在世界的哪个地方，你都会看到这些。所以我刚才在引言中提到，库德罗维茨博士，你的第一个玩具设计之一是一个会排泄的番茄酱瓶。伯根博士，你在最近几篇文章中被引述，谈到为什么孩子们对厕所幽默和排泄玩具如此感兴趣。既然我们这里谈到了便便的话题，为什么孩子们觉得浴室幽默和排便相关的玩具如此难以抗拒？
Well, why do adults laugh at jokes that have those same kind of elements? The only difference is that young children don't have a lot of experiences. So bathroom stuff is one of the few, quote, shocking things that you're not supposed to talk about. So obviously, that's the one they focus on. Their motivation, at least in my view, is absolutely no difference than the adult to tell some kind of a scatological joke or whatever. It's just that that's the material they have to act on and about being funny and being shocking. Scatological. Wow, I'm going to use that word in my book.
嗯，为什么成年人会嘲笑那些具有同样元素的笑话呢？唯一的区别是，幼儿没有很多经历。所以浴室里的东西是少数几个你本不该谈论的、所谓的令人震惊的事情之一。所以很明显，那是他们关注的焦点。他们的动机，至少在我看来，与成年人讲某种粪便笑话或其他什么绝对没有区别。只是那是他们可以据此采取行动、关于搞笑和令人震惊的材料。粪便。哇，我要在我的书里用这个词。
Yeah, I don't know. Potty humor, they get reinforced, right? Whether it's good or bad, but if, you know, the child says something, they're going to get laughs. You know, it could be uncomfortable laughs or it could be actual laughs or it could be scolding, but they get feedback and they know it will consistently get feedback. And so we've had a very hard time getting our five-year-old to stop saying, poop all the time. And it's just like ignoring it eventually is the... Yeah.
是的，我不知道。厕所幽默，他们得到了强化，对吧？不管是好是坏，但如果，你知道，孩子说了什么，他们就会引来笑声。你知道，这可能是尴尬的笑声，也可能是真正的笑声，或者可能是责骂，但他们得到了反馈，他们知道这会持续不断地得到反馈。所以我们很难让我们五岁的小孩停止一直说“便便”。这就像最终忽略它就是……是的。
Well, and I've done, you know, developmental study of children's humor. And you see, that's a particular stage. And later, they're going to do other shocking things or tell you a joke that wouldn't be appropriate either. But it's just that with humor, a lot of humor is designed to have some sort of shocking quality to it because that's what makes it funny. So you use whatever is available at your own experience level. And there's been some interesting study of, you know, the differences in men's and women's humor. And if you look at it closely, it has a lot to do with what have been their life experiences.
嗯，而且我做过，你知道的，儿童幽默的发展研究。你会看到，这是一个特定的阶段。后来，他们会做其他令人震惊的事情，或者讲一个同样不合适的笑话。但只是幽默的很大一部分旨在具有某种令人震惊的品质，因为这正是它有趣的地方。所以你可以利用你自己经验水平下可用的任何东西。并且有一些有趣的关于男性和女性幽默差异的研究，如果你仔细看，它与他们的生活经历有很大关系。
So it's just the same kind of thing. potty humor is very funny to young children because that's a very important thing in their life. If you recall, there's a lot of attention their adults have paid to how they manage that. So it's a good thing to make jokes about and to find funny. So shifting gears here, a few years ago, there were a number of news stories about major retailers such as Target, getting rid of boys and girls labels in their toy departments. I'm just wondering what role gender plays in kids' toy preferences and in how they play with toys. I mean, I think it's all fabricated to some degree by marketing.
所以这完全是同一回事。厕所幽默对幼儿来说非常有趣，因为那是他们生活中的一件大事。如果你回想一下，成年人对他们如何处理这件事给予了大量的关注。所以这是一个拿来开玩笑并觉得有趣的好事情。所以转换一下话题，几年前，有许多新闻报道称，诸如塔吉特（Target）这样的主要零售商在其玩具部取消了男孩和女孩的标签。我只是想知道性别在儿童玩具偏好以及他们如何玩玩具中扮演什么角色。我的意思是，我认为这在某种程度上完全是由营销捏造出来的。
And when I was little, I just wanted to play with the easy bake oven. But I think it was only in pink or something. That's all I wanted, right? And then it was like, no, that's a girl toy because it's, you know, it's pink. and it's cooking. I don't know. I thought that was weird. Now it's not.
当我小的时候，我只想玩那种轻松烤箱。但我想它只有粉红色或别的什么颜色。那是我唯一想要的东西，对吧？然后就变成了，不，那是女孩的玩具，因为它，你知道的，它是粉红色的，而且它是用来做饭的。我不知道。我觉得这很奇怪。现在不是了。
You know, it's in different colors. And for us, you know, we just, we get our kids whatever they want to play with. And we're trying not to say that is, that's a gendered thing. Sorry, our son has, you know, this probably more clothes that are labeled as girls' clothes in prior times. He has a lot of dresses and skirts. And I think with like art, what is the art class, I think that's the brand. It's just a lot of, it's all mixed up together. And there's no calling out.
你知道，它有不同的颜色。对我们来说，你知道，我们只是，我们给我们的孩子买任何他们想玩的玩具。我们尽量不说那是，那是带有性别色彩的东西。抱歉，我们的儿子有，你知道的，这可能比以前标记为女孩衣服的衣服更多。他有很多连衣裙和裙子。而且我认为比如艺术，艺术课是什么，我认为那是那个品牌。这有很多，全都是混在一起的。而且没有大喊大叫。
This is for a boy or a girl. And I think a lot more parents feel that way now than they used to. But the toy companies and the toy stores and all of them are still egregious about that because they are always determined to label boys' toys and girls' toys. I would agree with Barry that the typical child will play with anything that they find interesting, and there are times when dressing up is great for everybody, and there's times when pushing cars around are great for everybody to be doing. And so children would not be making those boy and girl distinctions if adults were not promoting that.
这是给男孩还是女孩的。而且我认为现在有更多父母有这种感觉。但玩具公司、玩具商店和所有这些地方在这方面仍然令人发指，因为他们总是决心给男孩玩具和女孩玩具贴标签。我同意巴里的看法，典型的孩子会玩任何他们觉得有趣的玩具，而且有时打扮对每个人来说都很棒，有时推着汽车到处跑对每个人来说也很棒。因此，如果没有成年人在宣扬这一点，儿童就不会做出男孩和女孩的区别。
And if you ask a lot of parents, unfortunately, even today, they would say, oh, I would only want to buy that for a boy or I don't want to buy that for a girl. But it's kind of working against that tide of advertisements and store directions to allow your child to have as wide a range of toys as they want to have as Barry's trying to do. And I do think it's worse now than it used to be. There was a one-time period in my professional career where, there was a real attempt to take those labels off of the toys and then it gradually crept back on everything again. So I'm hoping if it's the case that they're beginning to get rid of those labels again, it would be great. But I haven't seen much evidence of that as yet. That sounds like it probably mirrors what's happening politically in a given country or in the world.
如果你问很多父母，不幸的是，即使在今天，他们也会说，“哦，我只会给男孩买那个”或者“我不想给女孩买那个”。但这有点像在逆着广告和商店导向的潮流而行，允许你的孩子拥有他们想要的最广泛的玩具，就像巴里试图做的那样。而且我确实认为现在比以前更糟糕了。在我职业生涯的某个时期，曾有一次真正的尝试，试图把那些标签从玩具上撕下来，然后它又逐渐蔓延回到所有东西上。所以我希望如果他们开始再次撕掉那些标签，那将是极好的。但我目前还没有看到太多这方面的证据。这听落可能反映了特定国家或世界政治中正在发生的事情。
So I'm sure that you both know adults who continue to be fascinated with toys. Do we ever really outgrow them? Do our toys just get bigger and more complicated and maybe more expensive? I think you never outgrow it, but the labels change. So instead of it being, I'm playing with this, it's something else. I have a hobby that I collect dolls, or I have a hobby that I, fly plane, automatic planes or whatever. So play is a basic human characteristic. It is going to be present, hopefully, for all of us all our life. And we should have times when we're playful
所以我确信你们俩都认识那些继续对玩具着迷的成年人。我们真的会超越它们吗？我们的玩具只是变得更大、更复杂、可能也更贵了吗？我认为你永远不会超越它，但标签变了。所以它不再是，我在玩这个，而是别的什么东西。我有收藏洋娃娃的爱好，或者我有，开飞机、自动飞机或别的什么的爱好。所以游戏是人类的基本特征。希望在我们的一生中，它都会为我们所有人所呈现。我们应该有这样的时间，当我们充满玩心，
and we're enjoying things that aren't getting graded or don't have to be paid for, whatever. But I think that we call them by different names. As an adult, you're in a play maybe, but you're not playing. But you're still pretending. You're taking a role, you're acting, and so forth. So that's a playful type of activity adults would do. And that's true for a lot of other adult activities. But we don't call them play.
并且我们在享受那些不需要打分或不需要付钱等等的事情。但我认为我们用不同的名字称呼它们。作为成年人，你可能在戏剧中，但你不是在玩。但你仍然在假装。你扮演一个角色，你在表演，等等。所以这是成年人会做的一种充满玩心的活动。许多其他成年人活动也是如此。但我们不称它们为游戏。
We call them hobbies, or we call them hobbies, or we call them a whole wide of a range of things. So I don't know why the wordplay doesn't continue to get used as much as it should be because the playful quality of humans is one of our, in my view, best qualities. Yeah, I mean, some areas it stays, like when we're playing video games still as adults or we're playing sports, for example. But in general, it's not like, hey, guys, you want to come over my house and play, right?
我们称它们为业余爱好，或者我们称它们为兴趣，或者我们称它们为广泛的各种事情。所以我不知道为什么“游戏”这个词没有像它应该的那样继续被使用，因为人类的这种玩心在我看来是我们最好的品质之一。是的，我的意思是，在某些领域它保留了下来，比如当我们作为成年人还在玩电子游戏或者我们在进行体育运动时，例如。但总的来说，不是那种“嘿，伙计们，你们想来我家玩吗”，对吧？
You don't call your friends as an adult and say that, unless you're saying cards, maybe. Right. But yeah, the activities just get more challenging or they get more fine motor skills. So it goes from, you just think about puzzles, right? You're starting with the four-piece puzzle as a little baby and then, or a toddler,
成年后你不会给朋友打电话说这个，除非你可能是说打牌。对的。但确实，这些活动只是变得更具挑战性，或者它们需要更多的精细运动技能。所以它从，你只想想拼图，对吧？你作为一个小婴儿从四片拼图开始，然后，或者一个幼儿，
and you get to like the 100-piece puzzle. And then an adult, you're still doing, puzzles, but they're a thousand piece, right? And maybe they have like... And it's still fun. Yeah. And it's still fun, right? Or even skill-based, you know, it goes from like stacking, you know, or the Nerf blasters to archery or something, right? It's like your motor skills get better. Your budget gets higher. You can put more time and money into these hobbies or recreation. And we just start to not associate it with that word, because that word tends to mean
你到了像 100 片拼图。然后作为一个成年人，你还在做，拼图，但它们是一千片的，对吧？也许它们有……而且它仍然很有趣。是的。而且它仍然很有趣，对吧？甚至基于技能，你知道，它从像堆叠，你知道的，或者 Nerf 发射器到射击或类似的东西，对吧？就像你的运动技能变得更好。你的预算更高了。你可以把更多的时间和金钱投入到这些爱好或娱乐中。我们只是开始不把它们与那个词联系起来，因为那个词往往意味着
for kids or trivial, right? But it's still play. It's just, it's more fine-tuned. It's more advanced. Yeah. And we call it a hobby or we might just say, I want to do creative things. instead of saying play, I'm creating, and so forth. And I think that my one concern, I guess I'll have to say,
给小孩子玩的或微不足道的，对吧？但它仍然是游戏。它只是，它更精细调整了。它更高级了。是的。我们称之为爱好，或者我们可能只是说，我想做有创造力的事。而不是说玩，我在创造，等等。而且我认为我有一个担忧，我想我必须说，
going back to that earlier when we were talking about technology and how toys have now become so much more technologically designed, my view is the people who are having the playfulness or the people who are designing the stuff more than if it's a toy, that you can only do one or two things with. And so I would hope that as the toys got more sophisticated, that they continue to have many different ways they can be used. Because if a toy only has a few ways it can be used,
回到我们之前谈论技术以及玩具现在变得多么具有技术设计的那段，我的观点是，那些拥有玩心的人是那些设计东西的人，而不是如果它是一个玩具，你只能用它做一两件事的人。所以我希望随着玩具变得越来越复杂，它们继续拥有许多不同的使用方式。因为如果一个玩具只有少数几种使用方式，
it either is not going to be played with very much, or it's going to make children no longer having opportunities to play. If you're doing video games all the time or you're doing things that are very structured, you are not getting a chance to have wonderful ideas. There's been some really interesting research on adults who won McArthur Awards. And when they talked with a lot of them, they almost all said that what they most enjoyed when they were younger, was what was called small world play, which is a kind of play that's allowed for elementary and older-age kids.
要么它不会被怎么玩，要么它会让孩子们不再有机会去玩。如果你一直都在玩电子游戏，或者做一些非常结构化的事情，你就没有机会产生美妙的想法了。有一些关于获得麦克阿瑟奖的成年人的非常有趣的研究。当他们与其中许多人交流时，几乎所有人都说，他们年轻时最喜欢的事情被称为小世界游戏，这是一种适合小学及更大年龄孩子的游戏。
And it's like designing little structures where you make little towns or you make some kind of a small world. And then you still continue to interact in that small world. But it's appropriate for an older child. as compared to yourself taking on a pretend role or something like that. So the kind of play that older kids I hope still have is where they can actually create the worlds and do things themselves and not just rely on the technology that lets them go into somebody else's
就像设计一些小结构，你在其中建造小城镇或者某种小世界。然后你继续在那个小世界中互动。但这适合年龄稍大的孩子，而不是你自己去扮演一个假装的角色之类的。所以，我希望大一点的孩子仍然能玩的那种游戏是，他们可以自己创造世界并做事情，而不只是依赖于让他们进入别人世界的科技。
wonderful idea of what is play, where they don't really get to do their own, ideas of play. It sounds like you're also advocating for basically more unstructured time, right, for kids not to always be told now you've got to go play tennis because they may like tennis, but you're being forced to do it now as opposed to mom, I think I'm going to go out in the street now and play ball with the kids. And Barry's done a lot about creativity. So you might want to talk a little bit about creativity's requirement. for playfulness.
那种关于什么是游戏的美妙想法，在那里他们并没有真正去实现自己关于游戏的想法。听起来你也在主张基本上要有更多无结构的时间，对吧，不要总是告诉孩子们现在你得去打网球，因为他们可能喜欢网球，但现在是强迫他们去做的，而不是像“妈妈，我想现在上街去跟孩子们打球”。贝瑞在创造力方面做了很多研究。所以你可能想谈谈创造力对趣味性的要求。
Yeah, there's a number of studies that have shown you're more creative when you're playing or when you view an activity as play. And I think to just build off of the small world comment or the type of play, in today's world, a lot of adults and kids are building those imaginary worlds, but it's in the computer. And it's in Minecraft and Fortnite. And it is creative. You're building things.
是的，有许多研究表明，当你在玩耍时，或者当你把一项活动视为游戏时，你会更有创造力。我想顺着刚才关于“小世界”评论或游戏类型的话题说，在当今世界，许多成年人和孩子都在构建那些想象中的世界，但它们是在计算机里，在《我的世界》和《堡垒之夜》里。这确实是创造性的，你在建造东西。
You're making up your own stuff. But it's also on a screen. So I don't know. There's pros and cons there for sure. Yeah. I mean, there's something tactile. If you, for example, make dollhouses or you've got a train set and you've created a whole layout of towns and so forth. It's very different from the experience of doing it just on a lot.
你在编造你自己的东西。但它也是在屏幕上的。所以，我不知道。这里肯定有利也有弊。是的。我的意思是，有一种触觉体验。例如，如果你制作娃娃屋，或者你有一套火车模型，并且你创造了整个城镇的布局等等。这与仅仅在屏幕上操作的体验非常不同。
screen. So as we're moving into the holiday season, I think I open with this and people are out buying toys, do you have any guidance suggestions for parents who are looking for gifts for their kids, toys that, whether they're classics or there's something, I mean, I'm not asking you to endorse a particular brand or a product, but sort of the concept of what would you recommend parents be looking for as they're trying to get their kids' holiday presents? Wow. Okay. I get this a lot. And then I freeze. Board game-wise, going to my research on creativity, I have a lot of favorites that I think build creative skills. My favorite game is actually called code names. And it's a game about divergent thinking and convergent thinking. And it's a word game. But it's now branched out into different properties. So there's a Disney version and a Marvel version and a Harry Potter version. and so you're likely to find one that resonates with your child, but I really do like that game as far as the creative skills that it builds.
因此，当我们进入节日季时，我想我以此开场，人们外出购买玩具，对于那些正在寻找礼物给孩子的父母，你们有什么指导建议吗？这些玩具无论是经典款还是别的什么，我的意思是，我不是要求你们代言某个特定品牌或产品，而是关于父母在试图为孩子挑选节日礼物时应该寻找什么的概念？哇。好的。我经常遇到这个问题。然后我就卡壳了。从桌游的角度来看，结合我对创造力的研究，我有很多我认为能培养创造力的最喜欢的游戏。我最喜欢的游戏其实叫“代号”（Codenames）。它是一个关于发散思维和收敛思维的游戏，也是一个文字游戏。但它现在已经扩展到了不同的系列。所以有迪士尼版、漫威版和哈利波特版，所以你很可能会找到一个能与你的孩子产生共鸣的版本，但就它所培养的创造力而言，我真的很喜欢那款游戏。
I'm also partial to anything related to cooking and food, and I don't necessarily think it needs to be a toy version of a thing. So I'm not necessarily advocating for the easy bake oven. I'm advocating for maybe the kids' knife set that are actually, knives. And, you know, it's the safer knives, but they're still knives, right? And like the kid peeler, vegetable peeler. And if there's any other fun products that children can play with you in the kitchen,
我也偏爱任何与烹饪和食物相关的东西，而且我不认为它一定需要是玩具版本的物品。所以我并不一定是在提倡儿童简易烤箱。我主张的可能是真正的儿童刀具套装。而且，你知道，那是更安全的刀，但它们仍然是刀，对吧？就像儿童削皮器、蔬菜削皮器一样。如果还有其他好玩的儿童产品可以让你和他们在厨房里一起玩，
for example, like a pasta maker, right? The hand-crank pasta maker, at least once a month, the children view that as a toy. And we're making food together. And it's not that expensive of a kitchen tool. So just I guess think beyond the toy aisle is my recommendation. Okay. My suggestion would be sure to have some games that everyone in the family can play. If you think back to your childhood, you can remember some of the best times when your whole family gathered together and played some guys.
例如，像压面机，对吧？手摇压面机，孩子们至少每个月都会把它当成玩具。我们在 一起做饭。而且这个厨房工具并不贵。所以我想我的建议是跳出玩具走廊去思考。好的。我的建议是确保有一些全家人都能玩的游戏。如果你回想你的童年，你会记起全家人聚在一起玩某些游戏的一些美好时光。
and a game. It might not have been a very intellectual game, but it was something that you could do together. And one of the things you learn is how to be a little better sport, if you're not always the one who's coming out, winning the game. But I think that that idea of engaging with your family in play is a very important one. The other suggestion I would have is that the more open-ended toys you can provide the better in terms of play value. Things that can be used in a number of different ways. Maybe they start out a certain way, but then you can kind of transform them into other things. And also, the idea that they don't have to be the most popular kind of name toy brand or whatever, but very simple things. Balls, for example, are still extremely popular toys and just having
以及一个游戏。它可能不是一个非常智力的游戏，但它是你们可以一起做的事情。如果你不是总是赢得游戏的那个人，你学到的事情之一就是如何成为一个更好的输家。但我认为与家人一起参与游戏的这种想法非常重要。我的另一个建议是，就游戏价值而言，你可以提供的开放式玩具越多越好。可以以多种不同方式使用的东西。也许它们以某种方式开始，但随后你可以将它们变成其他东西。此外，它们不必是最受欢迎的知名玩具品牌等，而是非常简单的东西。例如，球仍然是非常受欢迎的玩具，只需拥有
a few different sizes of balls and playing with them, but you do need to have either other children to play with or family members to do it. And in my, a lot of my early research, I found kids used to play outside with a lot of other kids. And that seems to have been less common now. And so if they're not playing with other kids outside, then the family needs to play with them, or they have to play more with other kids at school, or somewhere where they can learn some of the give and take. And as Piaget would say, enhance their moral development. Well, thank you both. This has been really interesting. I hope that we provided some good advice and guidance to parents and other caregivers of children
几种不同尺寸的球并和它们一起玩，但你确实需要有其他孩子一起玩或有家庭成员来做这件事。在我的许多早期研究中，我发现孩子们过去经常和许多其他孩子在外面玩。现在这似乎不太常见了。所以如果他们不在外面和别的孩子玩，那么家人就需要陪他们玩，或者他们必须在学校或某个地方与更多的其他孩子玩，在那里他们可以学会一些礼尚往来。正如皮亚杰所说，增强他们的道德发展。嗯，谢谢你们俩。这真的很有趣。我希望我们为父母和儿童的其他看护者提供了一些好的建议和指导，
who are looking for toys, particularly around this time of year, but all the time, because toys are, there's no season, right? Toys are for all time. So thank you both. Thanks. Enjoyably be here. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们在寻找玩具，特别是在一年中的这个时候，但也一直都在寻找，因为玩具是没有季节性的，对吧？玩具是永恒的。所以谢谢你们俩。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。 《心理学对话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的音频剪辑师是 Chris Condihan。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。